the worst ever natural disaster in
Brazil's Southern State of Hugh Granger
the soul
entire neighborhoods underwater two days
after the storm struck more than 60
cities with no warning leaving behind a
trail of Destruction and despair
I feel devastated I lost everything but
there are many people who lost so much
more
Rescuers looking for survivors as the
body count continued to rise and
hundreds were still missing the governor
of Hugh Granger duso declared a state of
Calamity allowing government funds to be
freed up for search rescue and Recovery
hundreds have been rescued but
unfortunately many have died we now have
the largest amount of deaths caused by a
natural event in the history of Rio
Grande de soul
this man says he barely made it out of
his home
it was very sudden the water Rose two
meters in minutes all this was flooded
heavy rainfall forced 5 000 people out
of their homes many of them permanently
the storm was caused by an extra
tropical Cyclone experts say climate
change is to blame
climate change intensifies Cyclones like
the one that struck Rio Grande dussul
Cyclones and other weather phenomena
happened naturally but with global
warming they have become stronger and
more frequent
so the emergency is not yet over
forecasters say there's more rain on the
way Monica valjasira Rio de Janeiro
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera